Verfluchte Goldstatuen
aus Südamerika.
Magische Steine aus Nepal.
Das Atlantis der Wüste
und eine unentdeckte
Piratenkolonie
mit dem größten Schatz aller Zeiten.
Wie authentisch diese Storys sind:
Das klären wir jetzt.
Lange hat es gedauert, aber jetzt
kommt sie endlich in die Kinos:
Die Verfilmung der Abenteuer
von Schatzjäger Nathan Drake.
Gespielt wird er von Tom Holland.
Der Film
ist ein Prequel des 1. Teils.
Warum die Karte?
Hier entlang segelte Magellan.
Du kennst dich aus.
Wir kümmern uns heute
ausschließlich um die Spiele.
Neben Klettern und Ballern
geht es um viel Geschichte.
Überall im Spiel tauchen
historische Personen auf.
Ebenso historische Orte
und Ereignisse.
Wie viel davon stimmt?
Was hat das Studio dazugedichtet?
Das finden wir heraus mit dem
YouTube-Experten für Geschichte:
Mit MrWissen2go
Mirko Drotschmann.
Mirko ist ein YouTube-Urgestein.
Seit fast 10 Jahren
präsentiert er spannendes Wissen
rund um Politik und Geschichte.
Dieses Wissen ist informativ,
meinungsstark und am Puls der Zeit.
Kaum einer reagiert so schnell
auf das aktuelle Geschehen
wie MrWissen2go.
Mirko, schön, dass du da bist.
Hi.
Was ist mit Computerspielen,
die sich mit Geschichte beschäftigen?
Ich finde es total cool,
weil man eine ganze Menge lernt.
Und es muss stimmen.
Wenn etwas Ausgedachtes dabei ist,
muss es dabei stehen.
Sonst denkt man, so war es.
Das stimmt, man kann es auch checken.
Wir legen los mit Teil 1.
Der entstand schon 2007.
Das ist 15 Jahre her.
Wir brauchen eine Rückschau.
Jemand muss uns die Stories
kurz und knapp zusammenfassen.
Christoph vom Kanal "GAME TWO"
kennt sich mit Uncharted bestens aus.
Wir sehen unseren Helden,
wie er den Sarg
seines mutmaßlichen Vorfahren
Sir Francis Drake aus dem Meer birgt.
Darin findet er ein Tagebuch
mit Hinweisen auf den Standort
der goldenen Stadt El Dorado.
Er findet heraus,
dass El Dorado gar keine Stadt ist,
sondern eine riesige Goldstatue.
Sie wurde vor 400 Jahren
von den spanischen Eroberern geraubt.
Als er die Statue findet, stellt er
fest, dass ein Fluch auf ihr lastet.
Jeder, der sie öffnet,
wird in eine Art Zombie verwandelt.
Deshalb versenkt er
die verfluchte Statue im Meer.
Ob man als Spieler
mit leeren Händen da steht
oder etwas über die Geschichte
gelernt hat, liegt an euch.
Danke, Christoph.
Frage an dich, Mirko:
Gab es Sir Francis Drake wirklich?
Ja, es gab ihn.
Er ist auch ziemlich bekannt.
Er lebte von 1540-1596.
Er war im Auftrag
der britischen Krone unterwegs.
Er wurde tatsächlich
in einem Bleisarg bestattet.
Es stimmt, was im Spiel gesagt wird.
War er auch ein echter Pirat?
Er war ein noch coolerer Pirat.
Er war Freibeuter.
D.h. er war ein legaler Pirat.
Piraten waren eher Verbrecher.
Sie überfielen Schiffe.
Freibeuter
handelten im Auftrag von jemandem.
Drake handelte
im Auftrag der britischen Krone.
Er überfiel offiziell Schiffe,
raubte Dinge und zerstörte viel.
Er wurde dafür belohnt.
Das klingt cool.
Also stimmt der Hinweis
auf die Spanier?
Ja, die Spanier
waren die große Konkurrenz.
Drake musste sie daran hindern,
wertvolle Dinge zu transportieren.
Er raubte sie den Spaniern.
Die Spanier hatten im 16.
und 17. Jh. Kolonien in Südamerika.
Die Kolonien beuteten sie aus,
holten Gold usw. nach Spanien.
Auf dem Weg nach Spanien
fing Francis Drake die Spanier ab.
Die Person Drake ist authentisch,
die historische Einordnung stimmt.
Lass uns über El Dorado sprechen,
die Goldstatue, die Nate sucht.
El Dorado ist eher ein geflügeltes
Wort und steht für einen Ort,
wo man Schätze und Reichtum findet.
Woher kommt das?
Das mit der Statue
ist gar nicht so falsch.
Die Legende ist viel älter als die
Zeit, in der die Geschichte spielt.
Die Legende stammt von dem indigenen
Volk der Muisca aus Kolumbien.
Bevor ein neuer Herrscher
sein Amt antrat,
fuhr er mit einem Floß
auf einen Bergsee hinaus.
Der Herrscher war mit einer Paste
aus Gold eingeschmiert.
Er warf viele Edelsteine und Gold
in den See und sprang hinterher.
Daher kommt dieser Begriff:
El Hombre Dorado.
Also der goldene Mann
oder die goldene Statue.
Und so hat sich das
in das Spiel transportiert.
Suchten das die Spanier im 17. Jh.?
Ja.
Das war lange, nachdem diese Legende
zum 1. Mal verbreitet wurde.
Die Spanier
wollten diese Reichtümer.
Sie starteten
gefährliche Expeditionen.
Viele Menschen kamen ums Leben.
Gefunden wurde nie etwas.
Also ist El Dorado ein Mysterium,
und das gibt es nicht wirklich?
Man weiß es nicht.
Es ist wie mit dem Bernsteinzimmer.
Man hat es bisher nicht gefunden.
1969 fand man ein Artefakt:
ein Goldfloß.
El Dorado
könnte ein Floß gewesen sein,
mit dem der Herrscher fuhr.
Das zeigen Abbildungen
im Museo del Oro in Bogota,
der Hauptstadt Kolumbiens.
Das könnte ein Indiz dafür sein,
dass an der Geschichte was dran ist.
Dann müssen wir nur noch
die Sache mit den Zombies klären.
Über Zombies habe ich schon
in 2 Folgen ausgiebig gesprochen.
Die verlinke ich euch hier oben.
Ist das auch Teil
der El Dorado-Legende?
Oder warum wurde das
mit ins Spiel genommen?
Teil der Legende ist es nicht ganz.
Man ließ sich
von einer anderen Sache inspirieren.
Von den Expeditionen der Spanier,
die für viele Tote sorgten.
Sie stellten auch
eine große Gefahr dar.
Sie kämpften gegen indigene Völker
und gegen Krankheiten.
Malaria und andere Krankheiten,
die sehr gefährlich waren.
Sie verursachten viele Tote.
Ebenso der sog. Nigua-Floh,
der Krankheiten überträgt.
Dadurch entstehen
viele Geschwüre am Körper.
Dadurch
entsteht eine gewisse Zombie-Optik.
Je nachdem,
wie ausgebreitet die Krankheit ist.
Davon ließen sich
die Spiele-Entwickler inspirieren.
Von der Ähnlichkeit mit Zombies.
Von einer Meta-Ebene aus
könnte man sagen:
Die Gier nach Gold war ein Fluch,
der die Menschen traf und tötete.
Wir können festhalten:
Drake's Fortune legt ordentlich vor.
Viele historische Hintergründe
sind korrekt.
Alles, was darüber hinausgeht,
ist zwar ausgedacht,
hat aber realistische Bezüge.
Dieser Teil beginnt mit einem
Einbruch in ein türkisches Museum.
Nate findet eine alte Öllampe
mit einer Karte von Marco Polo.
Sie enthält Hinweise darauf,
dass Marco Polo
den Cintamani-Stein fand.
Er verleiht übermenschliche Kräfte
und befindet sich
an dem mystischen Ort Shambala.
Nate begibt sich nach Nepal, wo er
einen deutschen Forscher trifft.
Dieser leitete
zur Zeit des 2. Weltkriegs
eine Nazi-Expedition in den Himalaya,
um ebenfalls den Stein zu finden.
Mit dessen Hilfe findet Nate
Shambala und den Cintamani-Stein.
Allerdings hat er
nicht wirklich was davon,
weil am Ende alles zusammenbricht.
So ein Mist!
Hier wandelt Nate
auf den Spuren Marco Polos.
Wenn ich an meinen
Geschichts-Unterricht denke,
klingelt noch was.
Die meisten kennen ihn
wahrscheinlich von den Reiseführern.
Hilf mir auf die Sprünge.
Wer ist Marco Polo?
Reiseführer passt gut.
Diesen Mann gab es tatsächlich.
Er lebte von 1254-1324, reiste viel
und berichtete über diese Reisen.
Er war Sohn
einer Kaufmannsfamilie aus Venedig.
Er hatte enge Beziehungen
zu Kublai Khan,
dem Mongolen-Herrscher, Enkel von
Dschingis Khan und Kaiser von China.
In dessen Auftrag reiste er herum
und war auch in Nepal unterwegs.
Suchte er auf diesen Reisen nach
Shambala und dem Cintamani-Stein?
Wahrscheinlich eher nicht.
Er war unterwegs
und berichtete darüber.
Von ihm ist der berühmte Satz,
der im Spiel fällt:
"Ich habe nur die Hälfte von dem
berichtet, was ich gesehen habe."
Vermutlich sah er auch viel,
aber nach dem Stein suchte er nicht.
Die Entwickler des Spiels
gehen sehr locker um:
Mit Buddhismus, Hinduismus und
anderen Strömungen und Legenden.
Man kann davon ausgehen:
Das stimmt nicht.
Heißt das, dass der Cintamani-Stein
auch nur erfunden ist?
Eigentlich schon.
Es ist ein Edelstein, der angeblich
jedem einen Wunsch erfüllen soll.
Er wurde
der Wunsch-Edelstein genannt.
Er ist eine Reliquie.
Wie Buddhas Heiliger Gral?
Das gibt es sicher nicht.
Aber die Legende findet sich
im Buddhismus und im Hinduismus.
Das Wort ist Sanskrit und bedeutet
"Stein, der Wünsche erfüllt".
Ähnlich ist es mit Shambala.
Das ist im tibetischen Buddhismus
ein Ort, ein Reich,
in das die Buddhisten geflohen sind,
in Sicherheit vor den Barbaren.
Das gab es vermutlich auch nicht.
Aber das wurde alles
in einen Topf geschmissen.
Also so ähnlich wie bei El Dorado.
Das Studio nimmt alte Legenden
und erweckt sie neu zum Leben.
Es macht was völlig Neues daraus.
Der Cintamani-Stein und Shambala:
Das Eine hat mit dem Anderen
überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Aber im Spiel schon.
Jetzt wird es richtig spannend.
Im Spiel öffnet Nate das Tor
zu Shambala mit einem Schlüssel.
Dieser ist einem weiteren Gegenstand
aus der Mythologie nachempfunden:
Der Phurba.
Phurba sieht wirklich so aus
wie der Schlüssel in dem Spiel.
Es war aber kein Schlüssel,
sondern ein ritueller Gegenstand.
Man hat es kreativ
eingewoben und gesagt:
Das ist der Schlüssel zu Shambala.
Das ergibt
aus Entwickler-Hinsicht Sinn,
wenn man es mystisch
und fantastisch zusammenpackt.
Aber letztendlich ist die Fantasie
mit ihnen durchgegangen.
Sie bringen ja auch noch
die Nazis mit rein.
Jetzt wird es historisch
aber wieder korrekter.
Es gab 1938-1939
eine nationalsozialistische Mission
nach Nepal.
Im Auftrag von Heinrich Himmler,
Chef der SS und Fan der Mythologie.
Der Beauftragte wird im Spiel auch
korrekt benannt und heißt Schäfer.
Im Spiel heißt er Karl Schäfer,
in Wirklichkeit Ernst Schäfer.
Er war Zoologe.
Also das stimmt.
Was haben die Nazis dort gesucht?
Es geht, wie so oft, um 2 Dinge:
Um Kriegsvorbereitung, man suchte
kälteresistente Getreidesorten.
Man suchte robuste Pferde-Arten.
Und es ging um Rassewahn.
Man vermutete in dieser Region,
besonders im Himalaya,
ganz besondere Urtypen der Arier,
die Urtypen der Herrenrasse.
(Archivton) Ein ebenso
umfangreiches Zahlenmaterial
bringt
unser Rassenforscher zusammen.
Er misst die Schädel
und Körperformen der Eingeborenen.
Länge von Arm und Hand,
die Farbe der Augen und der Haut:
Alles wird notiert.
Wow!
Wir können zusammenfassend sagen:
"Among Thieves" ist ein wilder Mix
aus buddhistischer Mythologie,
aus den Abenteuerberichten von Marco
Polo und wahren Nazi-Begebenheiten.
Darauf muss man erst mal kommen.
Im 3. Teil sucht Nate
nach dem Atlantis der Wüste.
In einer unterirdischen Bibliothek
aus dem 16. Jh. findet er eine Karte.
Sie stammt
von seinem Vorfahren Francis Drake.
Der war auch auf der Suche,
im Geheim-Auftrag der Königin
Elizabeth I. & dem Berater John Dee.
Auch Kreuzritter und Lawrence von
Arabien waren der Stadt auf der Spur.
Alle ohne Erfolg.
Also muss Nathan wieder ran.
Die Stadt soll sich in der Wüste auf
der arabischen Halbinsel befinden.
Um den genauen Standort
herauszufinden,
muss Nate herumreisen
und 2 Hälften eines Amuletts finden.
Er muss sie zusammensetzen.
Das gelingt ihm, und so findet er
die verschollene Stadt.
Aber es gibt wieder
jede Menge Knall, Bumm, Päng,
und am Ende stürzt
die ganze Stadt in sich zusammen.
Hier taucht also Sir Francis Drake
wieder auf, aus dem 1. Teil.
Diesmal ist er im direkten Auftrag
der Königin von England.
Gibt es dafür historische Belege?
Nein.
Es ist unwahrscheinlich, dass er
im Auftrag der Königin handelte.
Er war Freibeuter.
Sie ließ ihn zum Ritter schlagen.
Sein Tun war anrüchig.
Er war ein halber Verbrecher.
Sie hielt aber viel von ihm.
Er war der Mann fürs Grobe.
Aber so wie es im Spiel
dargestellt wird, war es nicht.
Auch nicht in dieser Region.
1577-1580 machte er
eine Weltumsegelung.
Aber er war in Richtung Südamerika
unterwegs und nicht im Nahen Osten.
Man kann es also Seemannsgarn nennen
oder künstlerische Freiheit.
Was aber wiederum stimmt,
ist die Person John Dee.
Diesen Mann gab es wirklich.
Er war Berater von Elizabeth I.
Er war nicht nur Berater, sondern
ein sehr versierter Wissenschaftler.
Er war Universalgenie in Mathematik,
in Geographie.
Auch in Astronomie
kannte er sich aus.
Er hatte die damals größte
Bibliothek in Großbritannien.
Also ein sehr belesener Mann,
aber auch ein großer Fan von Magie.
Er stand auf okkulten Kram.
Das war in der Wissenschaft
damals üblich.
Er hatte dafür auch eine eigene
Sprache entwickelt: Henochisch.
Mit dieser Sprache sollte man
mit Engeln kommunizieren können.
Das ist natürlich Humbug.
Aber er hat diese Sprache angewandt,
ein Alphabet erstellt usw.
Das Amulett, das im Spiel vorkommt,
gibt es wirklich.
Es liegt im British Museum,
ist aber nicht magisch.
Das mit dem Henochisch
habe ich auch gelesen.
In der Infobox ist ein Link
für das Alphabet der Engelssprache.
Schaut mal rein und kommentiert
mal was auf Henochisch.
Das könnte witzig werden.
Na dann los!
Vieles um Nates Vorfahren,
die Königin von England
und John Dee ist korrekt.
Die Verbindung von Drake zum Atlantis
der Wüste ist ausgedacht.
Wie ist es bei Lawrence von Arabien?
Den gab es wirklich.
Der Ausdruck "Atlantis der Wüste"
stammt von ihm.
Er hat eine besondere Beziehung
zu der Region.
Er unterstützte die Araber
gegen die Osmanen im 1. Weltkrieg.
Es gibt einen Film von 1962.
Für uns ist wichtig:
Lawrence von Arabien versuchte
tatsächlich diese Stadt zu finden:
Dieses Atlantis der Wüste.
Er betrieb Forschung,
plante eine Expedition.
Aber er kam vorher
bei einem Motorradunfall ums Leben.
Es ist also nicht nur
die Person korrekt dargestellt,
sondern auch
die Verbindung zu dieser Stadt.
Gab es die Stadt wirklich?
Es gibt verschiedene Geschichten
über diese Stadt.
Im Koran
und in "1.000 und einer Nacht".
Laut Koran sollen die Bewohner
der Stadt in Sünde gelebt haben.
Allah bestrafte sie
mit einem Sandsturm.
Die Messingstadt wurde verschüttet.
Wir wollen niemandem
auf die Füße treten.
Der Koran hat sicher
sehr viele solcher Fakten.
Auch "1.000 und eine Nacht"
zieht seine Geschichten
aus irgendwelchen Erfahrungen.
Aber für uns sind es
keine wissenschaftlichen Quellen.
In diesem Fall stimmt es.
Diese Stadt gab es.
Sie heißt Ubar.
Man fand sie
in der Rub al-Chali-Wüste.
Wie im Spiel dargestellt.
Allerdings im omanischen Teil,
nicht im jemenitischen.
Man fand sie 1992.
Der Archäologe
und Filmemacher Nicholas Clapp
nahm Aufnahmen der Challenger, die
1984 ins Weltall geschickt wurde.
Er stellte fest:
Spuren einer Straße enden dort.
Das könnten Straßen gewesen sein,
die zu einem wichtigen
Zentrum führten.
Zu einem Weihrauch-Zentrum.
Das war Ubar damals.
Man suchte an der Stelle,
an der die Straßen endeten.
Tatsächlich fand man dann
dort die Stadt Ubar.
Und wie sah die aus?
Komplett aus Messing wie im Spiel?
Wahrscheinlich nicht, aber sie muss
sehr prächtig gewesen sein.
Man fand 8 Türme,
Tausende Überreste von Tonkrügen.
Diese Stadt war ein richtiges
Zentrum für Weihrauch gewesen.
Man fand auch Überreste
eines Weihrauch-Marktes.
Sie ging wohl auch unter,
aber nicht wegen eines Sandsturms.
Man vermutet, dass sie ca.
100 v. Chr. in sich zusammensackte.
Sie war komplett unterkellert.
Das wurde irgendwann
schwierig in der Wüste.
Die Mauern stürzten ein,
und die Stadt versank.
Das wirft noch mal ein ganz
neues Licht auf die Uncharted-Reihe.
Mit diesem Wissen merkt man:
In diesem Teil steckt superviel
geschichtliches Wissen drin.
Im 4. Teil geht es um Piraten.
Nate sucht nach dem sagenumwobenen
Schatz von Henry Avery.
Der Pirat machte
den größten Raubzug der Geschichte.
Alles von einem einzigen Schiff.
Diverse Hinweise
führen ihn nach Madagaskar.
Er erfährt, dass der Pirat eine Gang
mit anderen Piraten gegründet hat.
Das sind Bonny, Baldrige, Albasca,
Richard Want,
Edward England und Thomas Tew.
Mit ihnen soll Avery die freie
Piratenstadt Libertalia gebaut
und die Schätze
dort angehäuft haben.
Nate findet Libertalia
und den Schatz tatsächlich.
Allerdings lebten die Einwohner gar
nicht so miteinander wie erträumt.
Was ist passiert?
Fürs Protokoll:
Am Ende fliegt alles in die Luft.
Nate bleibt mit leeren Händen zurück.
Beute und Reisekosten
stehen in keinem guten Verhältnis.
Obwohl es zeitweise
so gut für Nate aussah.
Er fand Libertalia
und stand vor Henry Averys Stadt.
Und hier wieder die Frage:
Gab es Henry Avery
und Thomas Tew wirklich?
Ja, und sie haben auch
gemeinsame Sache gemacht.
Sie lernten sich 1694
auf Madagaskar kennen.
Sie gingen zusammen auf Beutejagd.
Das funktioniert auch.
U.a. bei dem legendärsten Beutezug,
dem sog. Ganj-i-Sawai-Überfall.
Was macht ihn so legendär?
Die Beute.
Es ging um ein Schiff
des damaligen indischen Herrschers.
Es war das mächtigste aller
Handelsschiffe, bestens bewacht.
600.000 Pfund waren auf dem Schiff.
In Gold, Silber und Edelsteinen.
Man könnte sagen:
600.000 ist viel,
aber doch nicht so unglaublich viel.
Umgerechnet wären das heute
150 Millionen Euro.
Für Gott und die Freiheit!
Ahoi, Matrosen!
Es gibt einen Widerspruch zu dem,
was im Spiel gezeigt wird.
Der Überfall gelang, aber Thomas
Tews Schiff wurde zerstört.
Er kam auch ums Leben.
Er bekam also nicht mehr mit,
wie man am Schluss siegte.
Er kann also danach mit Avery
keine Piratenstadt gegründet haben.
Tut mir leid.
Wir können also festhalten:
Diese krasse Beute
mit 150 Millionen Euro Wert gab es.
Den Überfall gab es,
die beiden Piraten gab es.
Aber nur einer der beiden hat es
überlebt, der andere ging drauf.
Es bleibt die Frage:
Hat Henry Avery die freie
Piratenstadt trotzdem gegründet?
Man weiß es nicht genau.
Es gibt ein Buch,
das auch im Spiel auftaucht.
Es heißt
"A general history of the Pyrates".
Es geht darum, dass eine
Piratenkolonie gegründet wurde.
Dort gab es direkte Demokratie,
freiheitliche Bürger
und auch ein sozialistisches
Wirtschaftssystem.
Das Buch wurde von Charles Johnson
im 18. Jahrhundert geschrieben.
Das stellt diese These auf.
Das ist dann aber Fiktion?
Man weiß es nicht.
Man weiß nicht einmal,
ob es Charles Johnson gegeben hat.
Es könnte auch Daniel Defoe gewesen
sein, der "Robinson Crusoe" schrieb.
Es gibt Quellen, z.B. Gerichtsakten,
die historisch verbrieft sind.
Es hat
eine Art Piratenkolonie gegeben.
Auf den Bahamas
in der Hafenstadt Nassau.
Und Henry Avery
soll etwas damit zu tun haben.
Inwiefern?
Er hatte sich einen mächtigen Gegner
mit dem Überfall ausgesucht:
Indien.
Indien stellte daraufhin
alle Geschäfte ein:
Mit der British-East-India-Company.
Das war ein Problem für die Briten.
Sie setzten ein Kopfgeld
auf Henry Avery aus.
Daraufhin floh Avery
auf die Bahamas nach Nassau.
Er bestach den Gouverneur
mit einem Teil des Beutegeldes.
Er gründete eine Piratenkolonie,
die bis 1718 existierte.
Avery tauchte unter.
Er nannte sich Benjamin Richman
und wurde nie wieder gesehen.
Hast du es?
Ja, Benjamin Richman.
Das ist Averys Deckname.
Was für eine Story!
Da sage noch einer:
Geschichte sei langweilig.
Null.
Eventuell geht ja auch
die Drake-Geschichte weiter.
In einem evtl. 5. Teil.
Wie würde euch das gefallen?
Welches historische Setting fändet
ihr gut für einen weiteren Teil?
Schreibt es bitte in die Kommentare.
Das hat Spaß gemacht.
Mirko, danke für deine Expertise.
Gern.
Hat es euch auch gefallen,
lasst einen Kommentar dazu da.
Gebt dem Video
einen Daumen nach oben.
Schaut bei Mirko vorbei
und bei Christoph von "GAME TWO".
Die Links zu beiden
packe ich mit in die Infobox
mit den unseren Quellen
für die Recherchen.
Vergesst nicht,
diesen Kanal zu abonnieren und ...
... Glocke drücken.
Bis zum baldigen Wiedersehen.
Wo wir gerade
beim Thema Videospiele sind.
Hier oben findet ihr
unser Assassin's Creed Video.
Eine unglaublich
spannende Spielereihe.
Wir haben uns damit beschäftigt:
Wer waren die Assasiden?
Wie brutal waren die wirklich.
Copyright Untertitel: MDR 2022